plot to Tomorrowland seems eerily
similar to what the film actually is the
movie is about a place where every
creative dreamer is taken and allowed to
explore any creative idea they want with
no limitations essentially that's the
film in a nutshell a whole bunch of
interesting and Imagi t'v ideas with
absolutely no limitations but the thing
is you kind of need limitations if not
you get kind of this disorganized
unfocused mess and yeah you can start to
see where the problem is the movie opens
with a rather awkwardly and funny
introduction by George Clooney who tells
the story about how he used to be a boy
genius he creates a rocket pack yeah
it's that kind of movie I guess and an
Android that looks like a little girl
takes into that wonderful place where
all creativity is welcomed Tomorrowland
cut to modern day where another little
genius named Casey is given a pin that
allows her to see Tomorrowland but not
quite get there when she tries to look
for more information about it suddenly
robots and all sorts of villains are
chasing her down the little Android from
before named Athena comes back into play
and she leads her to George Clooney who
in turn takes her to Tomorrowland why
because he apparently created a device
that could depict the end of the world
and guess what it's coming up
but his calculations show that Casey
might be the key in order to fix
everything
will they make it in time and stop an
evil genius played by Hugh Laurie from
making this self-fulfilling prophecy
come true
does Disney like really obvious tie-ins
to its theme parts literally having the
opening take place at one of their theme
parks I think you know the answer to
this okay so I'll start off with the
worst part the opening is awful the
writing it's horrendously bad this is so
weird because this is a Brad Bird film
he's usually very good at directing this
kind of stuff but ma'am every line is
about dreaming and wishing and whimsical
Ness and following your heart and all
that stupid stuff you hear on Disney
Channel movies just repeat it over and
over and over everything they say is
like a mini speech just nobody talks
normal when I first start watching it I
was thinking to myself oh man am I in
for a bad ride but luckily it does get a
lot better like when you do finally see
Tomorrowland it's very impressively done
and most of it just done in one shot the
action and comedy get a lot better too
with a lot of creative inventions in
fight scene
and on top of that they start throwing
in some really interesting ideas for
example Clooney when he was a little boy
falls in love with the Android naturally
he's going to get older and she's not
also on top of the fact that she's an
Android and quote-unquote can't feel
loved this could so easily be
uncomfortable seeing a grown man like
George Clooney kind of talking to this
little girl that he used to be attracted
to but it's played just right so you
feel more the tragedy of it rather than
the creepiness of it I know it sounds
weird downright disturbing but it's
actually kind of handled pretty well and
as you guess a lot of the ideas behind
the technology is very inventive the
device that lets you see into the future
in the way it operates is very cleverly
done just watching it you get a feeling
like you could handle it I love movies
that work that way like you feel like
you could actually kind of operate these
things in the trailers they show
Tomorrowland and looks grand and
phenomenal but in the movie that's all
you see in fact it's not even the real
thing without giving away too much
because actually it's kind of a clever
twist but when you do actually get there
it's very empty and lifeless I know
that's the point but wasn't the whole
focus of this movie to see Tomorrowland
we get one incredible long tracking shot
and that's it it's cool but that's the
name of the movie Tomorrowland it should
look awesome on top of that because
there's so much going on it's so much
information thrown at you so quickly
it's kind of hard to understand at times
for example Hugh Laurie says that the
world is doomed but Tomorrowland is
going to be fine well if that's the case
how come nobody's in Tomorrowland
anymore how come it almost looks
destroyed there's also this great big
long speech that's kind of explaining
why Hugh Laurie thinks the world kind of
should blow up and I don't know I can't
tell if it's actually really profound or
super preaching bottom line it's so
complicated you're still not quite sure
what the motivation is now don't get me
wrong a movie that really wants to
challenge you it's a different
philosophies and such that's welcomed
but the movie literally opened up with a
little boy creating a rocket pack and
flying it around Tomorrowland how are we
supposed to follow this incredibly
complicated philosophical technobabble
is this a fun little fantasy or a super
liberal that's trying to write out all
his aggressions even the acting seems
on-and-off George Clooney sometimes can
be very charming but then other times
his comedic timing is really off same
thing with Casey sometimes she talks
like someone her age and then other
times she just sounds so over-the-top
whimsical and shoving the message in
your face that's just irritating the
only thing that's constantly good
through it is the Android they pick a
really good actress to play her and yes
she has to do some very complicated
unique scenes with George Clooney and
this kind of not really sort of romance
that was going on
but she completely pulls it off and
she's totally convincing she's easily
the best part of the movie as for the
rest I don't know it kind of feels like
it's trying to be a dark and gritty Meet
the Robinsons except where the message
in that one while also hammered in was
kept very simple this one the entire
world depends on it if everybody doesn't
follow their dreams we're all going to
be destroyed it just seems a little too
extreme for me and much like the idea
behind the world itself I feel it does
need limitations it does need people to
say maybe not this maybe we should try
something else it's a cool thought to
see creativity just bloom and never be
filtered but I think the moral the story
would have been more interesting if he
was showing that limitations are needed
compromises are gonna have to be made
I'm still happy I saw it if for anything
else just for a lot of these creative
and unique ideas but tone wise it's all
over the place sometimes it feels very
adult sometimes it feels unbelievably
childish sometimes the effects are
amazing sometimes they're ridiculous
sometimes it's whimsical sometimes it's
boring sometimes it's slow sometimes
it's too fast it's about as an even a
film as you can get me personally I like
it when ideas are sort of trapped in my
brain and can soar fiddle around in
there so I can definitely take that from
it but if you're looking for a movie
that's much more put together and easy
to follow sadly it seems like it's
another dream away